william pascal la mer vous avez été
reconnu coupable d'homicide est condamné
au poisson jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive
je souhaitais vous dire quelque chose
avant votre exécution je sais pas
combien de temps j'ai droit pas bon donc
on viendra te plais pas le manquer les
problèmes si cela est encore aussi à
minuit on devra remettre couvert besoins
et la mer soit parler on va laisser
parler c'est la loi alors on change la
loi et on en parle plus avant les
élections en tout cas où était brodé
que vous soyez vosges coupeau madame
sous vos pieds dans l'ombre
anne hommel a les panneaux réciter tout
victor hugo sinon on n'est pas couché
william parce que la mère se trouve la
faille dans le système judiciaire pourra
mettre son exécution en 5 à proposer au
peuple et en profiter pour augmenter
votre cote de popularité voulais filmer
mon exécution par épisode des prisons
par plateaux télévision vous vous
trouvez pas télégénie comprends vous
foutez le visage ton visage à toi tu te
fous tout de suite encore une condamné à
mort qui sauve sa peau tous les soirs en
racontant des histoires c'est aberrant
j'adore le concept c'est le time and the
king show vient de la mer cela coli dont
tout le monde parle à tous les jours on
nous faisait répéter et 15 cigarettes
tous les jours on fait semblant on en
est où dans les chiffres je trouve que
j'ai la gueule d'un mec qui fait
semblant et les gens l'adorent
henri gabrysz faisait semblant les
électeurs regarderont chaud plus vous
aurez droit
ils sont là ils existent
tout ça ici structure de moi quand moi
[ __ ] j'existe
je vois du vide tu viens de choses
j'ai quelqu'un suivi mon dieu mort qui
parlait on devrait le laisser raconter
son histoire jusqu'au laissé mon âme est
forte surtout messieurs le buzz